politique chargé est d'abord de ce duel
deux meetings entre eux marine le pen et
eric zemmour lui était à lille elle
était tard ans pour lancer sa campagne
on regarde ce sujet de quentin calmer
avec marion delpech
ils étaient 4000 samedi venus de toute
la france pour lancer officiellement la
campagne avec au passage l'inauguration
de ces treize autocar bleus qui doivent
sillonner la france pendant les
prochaines semaines un meeting du
rassemblement national qui se tient le
même jour que celui d'eric zemmour à
lille une concurrence que les militants
feignent d'ignorer bon allez je suis ici
onzième hausse et un candidat comme un
autre comme macro comme à tout se
fait totalement abstraction de ces mots
ce qui est vraiment important c'est
marine sa campagne sa proposition son
programme donc rendre aux français leur
argent et leur pays et franchement on
s'occupe que de ça et
avancer nos idées et nos convictions
mais les cadres du parti hans ont
conscience cette concurrence politique
affaibli mécaniquement marine le pen
pour le président du parti jordan
bardella la campagne d'eric zemmour ne
vise qu'à parasites et celles de marine
le pen poté pour eric zemmour
aujourd'hui en tout cas dans les
sondages pour affaiblir la candidature
de marine le pen c'est évidemment risqué
en second tour décret ce maquereau or je
pense que ce n'est ni nos électeurs
disent les électeurs d'eric zemmour le
souhaitent ainsi pour marine le pen et
en une heure de discours la priorité
était d'attaquer le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron comme pour ignorer la
concurrence d'eric zemmour avec à la clé
cette séquence inédite ch la candidate
d'extrême droite devant la tribune sur
un ton solennel elle évoque les épreuves
de la vie j'avais dit que dénonce
politique quand j'étais petite fille à
l'école on m'a fait payer l'engagement
de mon père des persécutions
quel esprit d'une enfant associant tu ne
peux pas vraiment comprendre
les persécutions qu'ils me font aux
nières aujourd'hui toute idée de
discrimination
j'en mesure la justice j'en connais
une posture plus humaine aussi pour se
différencier d'eric zemmour la candidate
du rassemblement national espère ainsi
adoucir son image et montré un visage
moins agressif
à reims où elle a présenté sa vision ses
mesures son projet mais c'est vrai que
ce qu'on retient finalement c'est cette
fin un peu surpris ce passage où elle
s'est avancée sur la scène et où elle a
parlé d'elle de sa vie personnelle de sa
vie politique ces nouveautés sachez
marine le pen de fendre l'armure et de
jouer le côté personnel tout neuf c'est
nouveau meeting oui ça c'est sûr mais
elle l'avait fait dans une émission de
divertissement il y à quelques quelques
semaines déjà non si vous voulez il y
avait ul tout le monde l'a dit
médiatique
bataille entre eric zemmour et marine le
pen et c'est vrai que en amont on
pensait que l'avantagé était plutôt du
côté d'eric zemmour parce que il arrive
parce qu'eric zemmour c'est un pont du
nouveau sur le marché politique donc
l'effet nouveauté joue aussi il faut
jamais le négliger ensuite parce que bon
ils ont démontré du côté de chez zemmour
qu'ils avaient une capacité de
mobilisation dans les meetings qui était
réel une capacité aussi j'allais dire de
mobilisation sur les réseaux pour
accompagner les grands événements de la
campagne d'eric zemmour dont il y avait
à savoir faire qu'ils pouvaient sur le
plan médiatique finalement favorisé eric
zemmour dans cette bataille instantanée
entre les deux meetings là en
l'occurrence elle a réussi quelque chose
il faut l'admettre c'est que elle a
réussi à attirer malgré tout le les
projecteurs sur son meeting d'abord il
ya une mobilisation qui était à peu près
correct au regard peut-être un peu moins
que les zemmour mais qui était assez
correcte et elle a réussi quand même à
attirer les projecteurs médiatiques à
partir de cette confession où elle s'est
livrée où elle a voulu d'une certaine
manière expliqué qu' elle était
de ce point de vue là elle a réussi à
équilibrer si vous voulez d'une certaine
manière le regard médiatique que l'on
porte aujourd'hui sur les deux
événements d'autres termes l'événement
de zemmour n'a pas cannibalisé
totalement l'événement de marine le pen
et ça c'était quand même le principal
défi dans cette séquence lors appris ça
se trouve dans 48 heures tout cela sera
parfaitement oublier quand même nom mais
je partage jusqu'au dirno benedetti
j'irai même plus loin cette séquence
elle avait un peu fait en 2011 au
congrès de lyon en 2012 pendant la
campagne en se présentant comme une
femme une personne divorcée qui a élevé
seule ses enfants lcl veut pousser un
avantage qui est très paradoxal par
rapport à ces campagnes présidentielles
précédentes aujourd'hui ici et
maintenant elle n'est pas en certitude
d'être au second tour on parlera
peut-être de sondages où elle est
parfois deuxième comme à l'ifop
troisième chez des confrères à moi mais
son image s'est complètement rétabli
quand je vois dans le baromètre match
que la 40 % de bonnes
l'opinion qu'ont on a une enquête pour
tf1 qui montre que 43 % des français
pensent qu'elle a l'étoffé d'une
candidate à
la stature pardon présidentiel
ce qui frappe c'est cette envie de
pousser cet avantage sur son image et
créer de la proximité identificatoires
je vous ressemble vous me ressemble et
je suis votre porte parole d'ailleurs
par rapport la distinction eric zemmour
qui quand même qu'ils impriment une
certaine radicalité une certaine dureté
ya l'électorat féminin marine le pen
dans certaines vagues de notre rowling
est tout simplement en tête de tous les
candidats dans l'électorat féminin en
tout cas elle surclasse eric zemmour
c'est cette montage qu'elle pousse qui
est très inédit par rapport à ces
campagnes précédentes c'est justement
sur l'électorat est ce que l'électorat
aujourd'hui on est un petit peu plus de
60 jours du premier tour est ce que
l'électorat zemmour et l'électorat le
pen il est très distincts ou est-ce
qu'il ya encore des vases communicants
entre les deux le vase communicant
principal c'est le vote présidentiel le
pen 2017 ou eric zemmour parvient à
capter 25 % entre 20 et 25% de cet
électorat pour autant je suis frappé de
voir que dans les segments historique du
rassemblement national c'est à dire les
jeunes
les catégories populaires les personnes
peu diplômées les petites classes
moyennes marine le pen est nettement en
tête eric zemmour sur place ou devance
nettement marine le pen ou mort dans un
électorat potentiel frontiste auprès de
catégorie à ces nouvelles personnes
âgées cadres supérieurs professions est
un média c'est là que marine le pen est
en retard par rapport à grimaud on est
quand même sur des électorats qui ne se
superposent pas complètement c'est vrai
que sur cette stratégie d'image de
marine le pen c'est intéressant et
jouent clairement cette carte de la
corde sensible en 16 mois dans cette
séquence à reims où elle parle d'elle
pendant dix minutes et des difficultés
notamment qu'elle a vécu enfant des
persécutions à cause de l'engagement
politique de son père ça s'est vu
également la semaine dernière avec tous
les rallyes de son camp à eric zemmour
et notamment le probable possible
ralliement de sa nièce marion
maréchal-le pen avec cette séquence de
marine le pen et qui finalement était
touché en tout cas c'est comme ça
qu'elle le jouet voilà touché jusque
dans sa chair parce qu'elle avait
participé à l'éducation de marion ou
même quand elle réagissait à madrid et
bien aux
probables hésitations de nicolas bay est
là encore c'était le matin on la sentait
fatigué énervé voilà elle joue à cette
carte de l'émotion et ça s'inscrit aussi
dans un discours où elle essaye de se
différencier vis-à-vis d'eric zemmour et
elle insiste de plus en plus sur la
dureté d'eric zemmour elle parle des
nazis qu'il y aurait dans le camp du
parti reconquête et ce discours là aussi
qui pointe la dureté d'eric zemmour on
l'entend parfois chez maintenant chez
les militants du rassemblement national
là on a le discours de l'abstraction
mais on commence à entendre chez
certains militants que finalement
exercer un candidat trop dur avec du
racisme des discriminations et que voilà
ce ne serait pas cette image de marine
le pen je vais la carte affective comme
elle le fait ça peut payer mais ça paye
parce que qu'est-ce qu'une
présidentielle c'est une affaire
d'émotion c'est une affaire
d'incarnation ce n'est pas et or ne le
dira très bien c'est pas que quelqu un
catalogue de mesures un programme une
vision c'est aussi une incarnation et le
fait que pour c'est vrai dans un dans un
meeting pour la première fois elle
fendre l'armure le terme est un peu
galvaudé pourrait lui donner des
bénéfices d'image qui sont déjà puisque
son image a radicalement changé par
rapport à sa campagne à précédente
oui c'est sûr que la carte de l'affect
est très importante c'est encore une
fois la rencontre d'un homme d'une femme
avec un peuple à l'élection
présidentielle il faut épouser la france
d'une certaine manière être en mesure de
l'épousé de montrer qu'on est capable de
l'épousé c'est ça qui est important
ensuite bon si vous voulez il ya
d'autres sujets c'est à dire que moi je
pense que le distinguo entre une partie
de l'électorat d'eric zemmour et celui
de marine le pen c'est que peut-être
l'électorat d'eric zemmour est peut-être
plus politisé plus structurée dans sa
relation à la politique connaît les
l'électorat de marine le pen l'un des
enjeux pour marine le pen ça sera
finalement le niveau de participation
c'est à dire que elle pourrait être une
candidate qui souffrent plus de
l'abstention que eric zemmour par
exemple donc on l'a vu lors des
dernières élections régionales où un
certain nombre de segments sociaux qui
auraient dû se mobiliser pour elles ne
sont pas allées enfin tout cas pour ces
candidats ne sont pas allés voter donc
elle a un vrai sujet là dessus c'est à
dire un sujet de mobilisation de son de
sa sociologie électorale parce que là si
elle arrive en effet à mobiliser sa
sociologie électorale on peut imaginer
qu'elle puisse être largement dans fa
largement elle puisqu'elle puisse être
devant eric eric zemmour qui me semble t
il à une configuration en terme
d'électorat un peu différente peut-être
plus idéologiques plus plus encore une
fois mobilisé politiquement que
que celui de marine le pen et on va on
va parler d'eric zemmour lui il était à
lille et moi lui l'a plutôt de tenter de
séduire un électorat dur des
républicains oui avec un meeting
consacré au pouvoir d'achat eric zemmour
a d'abord commencé son meeting pardonner
sa propre définition du pouvoir d'achat
une définition effectivement rien de
très libérale l'état nous prendraient
trop d'argent écoutez le pouvoir d'achat
c'est l'argent qui vous reste qu'on les
arrête de toujours prendre le pouvoir
d'achat c'est ce que vous gardez qu'on
vous avez payé les charges qui pèsent
sur votre salaire la délégation
sacha les taxes sur votre plein
d'essence votre info sur le revenu votre
redevance télé aux apollo
taxe foncière le pouvoir d'achat c'est
ce que lille à monia pour
quand ils vous laissent quelques jours
et donc pour augmenter ce pouvoir
d'achat des français eric zemmour
propose donc et bien une baisse massive
des taxes qui pèsent sur le travail il
propose donc de diminuer les cotisations
salariales et patronales sur les
salaires pour que ça profite à la fois
aux salariés et à l'entreprise il a
annoncé hier une prime à zéro charges
sans cotisation qui peut être versé
chaque année un salarié et qui peut
s'élever et bien à hauteur de trois mois
de salaire net et puis eric zemmour
reprend également à la fameuse
défiscalisation et désocialisation des
heures supplémentaires mesure phare de
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 supprimés par
françois hollande en 2012 en l'écoutant
oui travailler plus pour gagner plus
était un excellent prasidh et oui
l'exonération de charges et
l'avilissement
leurs suppléments et est unique c'est
mais voilà on avait valérie pécresse qui
a ressorti le kärcher de nicolas sarkozy
maintenant on à eric zemmour qui
ressorte le travailler plus pour gagner
plus c'est fou comment nicolas sarkozy
inspire les candidats de 2022 alors
qu'une fois qu'une fois qu'eric zemmour
et bien annoncé toutes ces mesures
pouvoir d'achat une question se pose
comment les finances t-il et bien pour
les émaux c'est tout simple il fait des
économies sur le budget consacré à
l'immigration a fini à l'aide médicale
d'état fini également la prise en charge
des jeunes mineurs isolés et puis avec
eric zemmour la france n'accueillerait
plus qu'une dizaine de demandeurs
d'asile par an on va écouter règlement
sur ces économies faites sur les
migrations
vous le savez
tous les français le savent il y a le
financement de l'immigration oui mes
amis sauvé le pouvoir d'achat des
français s'est également arrêté de
financer l'immigration sur votre dos
c'est arrêter de dilapider l'argent
brigands peau même façon
oui le monde entier et puis enfin autres
économies proposées par exe morale à 100
de l'audiovisuel public français excite
france télévisions radio france qui
selon lui sont des jeux sites des médias
de gauche donc voilà ça ferait une
économie de 4 milliards d'euros et on a
vu alors on est venu chez marine le pen
et chez eric zemmour un même thème alex
le rappeler le pouvoir d'achat sauf
qu'on a l'impression qu'on a eu deux
stratégies différentes marine le pen
allait se servait du pouvoir d'achat
pour dire je peux être là candidats
d'autre chose que de l'immigration et de
la sécurité je suis la candidate du
pouvoir d'achat et l'eczéma ou même
quand il parle de pouvoir d'achat ils
ramènent toujours tout à l'immigration
oui en fait il tient le discours qui
était celui de jean marie le pen dans
les années 80 encore une fois si vous
regardez quel était le dispositif
politique de jean-marie le pen dans les
années 80 vous trouvé un écho qui est
quand même un écho assez saisissant avec
la façon dont aujourd'hui eric zemmour
présentes sur notre politique c'est à
dire assez libéral sur le plan
économique est évidemment nationaliste
sur le plan politique c'est d'une
certaine manière cet arc là qu'il est en
train d'essayer de restaurer et ça a
plutôt bien fonctionné en tout cas dans
les études d'opinion et dans les
sondages ces derniers ces derniers mois
alors que marine le pen est sûre tout
autre j'allais dire dispositif un tout
autre curseur où elle a dix ont une
vision qui apparaît beaucoup plus social
que celle de d'eric zemmour eric zemmour
d'une certaine manière qu'est ce qui le
qu'est ce qu'il était en train de
présenter à lille c'est tout simplement
le discours sur la préférence nationale
assez c'est assez c'est assez clair en
la matière un quand tu me dis qu'ils
réservent un certain nombre de
prestations sociales d'abord aux
nationaux et qu il en exclut les
immigrés c'est tout simplement le
discours de la préférence nationale que
l'on entend plus au rassemblement
national donc là en effet il ya une
ligne de fracture c'est à dire que au
delà de la concurrence je vais dire
entre de deux individus en quête de
d'une élection présidentielle il ya en
effet des clivages qui sont apparues au
sein de cette de cette droite là et où
on voit que marine le pen est celle
d'avoir un discours qui était un
discours qui est certainement beaucoup
plus consensuel parce que elle vise le
second tour et sait très bien qu'au
second tour si elle veut être crédible
pour éventuellement l'emporter face à
celui que tous les sondages pour
l'instant dans nos second tour
c'est-à-dire emmanuel macron il faut
qu'elle soit capable de rassembler plus
largement
pression qu'ils aient très clairement
les électeurs des républicains en
vantant les mérites de nicolas sarkozy
ça prend
oui dans le sens où dans notre quête
quotidienne le rolling chaque jour on
voit que il arrive à capter de soutien
d'un électeur françois fillon sur cinq
et c'est vrai que il ya une homme on a
parlé des zones sociodémographiques de
recoupements ou de décalage entre les
mots en marine le pen ici même on inclut
valérie pécresse emmanuel macron il ya
un segment qui peut être un segment à
conquérir pour les quatre c'est la
france du travail la france du salariat
celle qui a en 2007 crû fortement au
travailler plus pour gagner plus qui a
été extrêmement déçu que la droite a
perdu rappelez-vous la phrase d'andré
malraux sur le gaullisme c'est le métro
aux heures de pointe basse de ce point
de vue là c'est complètement perdus on
l'a vu avec lectorat fillon de 2017 qui
était absolument pas très peu on
électorat salariés ils avaient de
mémoire obtenu 10 à 12 % chez les
salariés du secteur privé c'est quand
même très faible et c'est vrai que c'est
un électorat qui vote c'est un électorat
qui est extrêmement puissants à côté de
l'électorat
inactifs ou âgées et aujourd'hui cet
électorat est chez marine le pen et
surtout chez emmanuel macron et c'est
vrai que valérie pécresse envoie aussi
des messages à cet électorat eric
zemmour savait qu'en reprenant de
manière très directe wright sur pour
ellis mais ce cardiaque ce qu'a dit
arnaud qui est extrêmement justes c'est
la référence j'en ariste puisque c'est
vraiment le lien se systémique entre
immigration et toutes les autres
thématiques je marierai pas détériore
encore plus loin il y avait même proposé
des années 80 dû supprimer l'impôt sur
le revenu de havas que l'état était un
état prédateur
du côté juste du côté d'eric zemmour
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la cible c'est
l'électorat avec le big 1 parce que il a
compris que aujourd'hui c'est marche
peut-être de progression du côté de
l'électorat de marine le pen était pour
l'instant un peu bloquée et donc il faut
qu'il aille puiser dans ce camp là pour
essayer de redonner une dynamique
électorale à sa campagne et c'est clair
que si valérie pécresse n'arrive pas à
avoir une deuxième dynamique à second
élan on peut on peut en effet craindre
une hémorragie d'une partie de
l'électorat républicain vers l'offre
d'eric zemmour là c'est une hypothèse
on suivra
[Musique]